CHRIS LEI: Building the next
great Android app isn't enough.
You can have the most amazing
social integration, best API
coverage, and the coolest
filters, but none of that
matters if your app is slow
and frustrating to use.
And that's why Udacity and
Google created the Android
Performance Course
to help you learn
how to make fast, smooth, and
awesome experiences for users.
The course reviews the
performance pillars
of rendering, compute,
memory, and battery.
And it uses the tools
in Android Studio
to find and fix
performance problems.
By the end of course,
you'll understand
how common performance problems
arise from your hardware, OS,
and application code.
And using profiling
tools to gather data,
you'll identify and fix
performance bottlenecks,
so users can have that smooth,
60-frames-per-second experience
that will keep them
coming back for more.
#PerfMatters-- for
more information,
visit udacity.com/google.